junge das ist ein witz vater mal runter
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück bei der
pyjamaparty 9 zusammen mit komme die
audi ag
ich möchte man meinen heute oder in der
folge hier bin ich dran mit trollen weil
er hat mich der letzten folge versucht
mit seinem blöden bogen fertig zu machen
nur weil gerade der schwächere bin er
geht immer auf die schwächeren hier
sozusagen los ja ja mensch das tut mir
auch sehr leid das stimmt übrigens alles
gar nicht ich muss mich da wirklich
verteidigen
nur ich habe mein anwalt sage ich jetzt
erstmal gar nichts zu ok ja da schafft
übrigens ne ja ich auch dass wir überall
weißt du ich sagen alles läuft
nein bin ich überhaupt richtig wohl muss
denn hin
ein schein weißt du doch nicht wie der
hase läuft
sitzmann wo muss ich hin auf dem baum
darf hier so ein trottel olibet
ich bin jetzt auf dem raum gegangen und
vorhaben das teil war der gleiche sprung
es regt auf so jetzt aber was ist wenn
ich auf den bomben muss ich jetzt sind
auf den nächsten baum hatte er vier ist
kein anderer
[Gelächter]
besteht hier und natürlich ist als ob du
doch wie schlägt ich will dir skelett
schlag ich wollte das treffen
na klar wie viel ausgegangen
jawohl ich habe es geschafft die kiste
21 da habe ich über 10
jawohl und welch ein glück dass hier mit
einem schlag okay ja ja genau dass man
viel machen fick dich so jetzt geht's
los
oh mein gott mein gott mein gott du
brauchst moment für die komplette
staffel hier hätte ich nie bekommen
glaube ich mal im ernst
stell dir vor ich hätte die ich war
gerade da passt man mauszeiger drauf
jetzt kommt wo müssen wir lange du hast
mein gehabt das ist ein witz war und ich
[Gelächter]
glücklich voll witzig ja ich hätte ja
krass viel gelacht du die komplette
karte einfach mal luft gesprengt dass es
nicht weitergeht
du nicht hier oben aus geht es weiter
hey willst mich verarschen
geht ähnlich ich fühle das wäre eine
gute erfolge für mich doch nicht kalt da
kommt man wie können wir glaube ich doch
da aus
darunter müssen wir ja mensch da müssen
wir die lang so ok hier lang natürlich
verstehen der checkpoint ja da war ja
schon am 12
natürlich müssen wir hier sagen er ist
auch ein guter orientierungssinn gutes
gedächtnis
schlag mich ja nicht okay schlag mich ja
ich hab ich gesagt hab mich ja auch
nicht
[Musik]
und von hier aus hat springreiter
sprunger finde ich ok ich nicht ich
schon ich habe die leute springen
nein aber jetzt kann ich sogar schon von
dem leiter schaffen ich bin auf den baum
drauf und auf bäumen waren immer viele
punkte er pustete sich gleich wieder
bestimmte mich nicht ich laufe jetzt
selber welche aufnehme der einzige grund
ja so was mache ich hier
nein ich bin so ein fehler
ich bin vom baum herunter gefahren wo
bist du schlecht denn du bist ja noch da
unten ja ich war auch ganz unten oben
eben hdf was gar nicht
ich war eben oben aber welche mutter
gefallen fall nicht
ich wollte sie nicht machen
ach wie so stürzte dann sofort komme
woran liegt das ja an meiner nackten
brust
ach man nicht hassen diese kleider
spanien so unglaublich da kann ich
endlich mal etwas vorsprung rausholen
obwohl ich war doch gerade oben alt aber
sollen dass hier schon wieder als du
dann muss man sich richtig konzentrieren
so entspannt war oder einfach nur
aufregend ich weiß aber nicht wie man
hier weiter macht na klar ich hab sie
hoch geschafft wo stand ist plötzlich in
wien hier müssen wir auf 8 verstehen und
nachreifen
ale aber nicht aber nicht lover lover
nicht wie wir dieses wort nicht machst
einfach nicht weil ich schlecht bin
sondern ich mache einfach um ihn auch
nicht das sind immer die faule ausreden
hier von ihren von ihr erwartet stark
und ich bin da und was ist denn das
würde überpowert es schwer haben
gefordert ich doch nicht immer alter da
ist auf einmal wieder in mir mensch du
das ist so unglaublich kommen jetzt hier
weiter ich bitte deine sprüche waren
aber auch da schon mal das andere nicht
mitfliegen er mit mit frieden nicht
mitfliegen
[Musik]
hier war alles voller kisten kunden ich
überrascht und ein bruder geguckt junge
junge ich stehe da drin nicht ich war
schon beim dritten coup gerade jedoch
weil brunnen und wie ist das wasser das
[Musik]
war schon flüssig da wo willst du jetzt
man abgeschaut auf die kiste ist auf dem
bau machen
ich mache das jetzt mit ich kann doch
geht
[Musik]
mario mario czaja mit natur nach ist der
heilige weiß ich glaub auch wenn du alle
kriegsdienst in dieser karte gibt ich
wollte gerade daran die kante geben
dann habe ich trotzdem noch gewonnen ich
glaube nicht an ich war gerade noch in
die kante geben
ich weiß ich gerade auch an die kante
geben erlernt von mir da waren wir noch
nicht drin in der burg vielleicht ist
das ja schon die antwort kann er sein
so wird schnell weiter hier punkte ja wo
ich dachte schon ich schlag dich da auf
dem blog auf
[Musik]
ist sehr freundlich doch nicht immer
ganz gelesen ja ich habe mich glaube ich
hab's nicht ob ich habe ja keinen
gedanken
verdammt verdammt verdammt verdammt was
warum findet er die kunst ja ich
verstehe es nicht
ich bin christ ich killer
du hast modus drin und das ist das
eigentliche programm
[Musik]
ich bin da ganz ehrlich ich hatte noch
nie nur durch drauf aber niemand
[Musik]
aber nicht ich dachte schon das ende der
welt oder eine kiste
die hatte ich doch schon gelutscht
ich hätte tun dürfen sich jetzt fünf
punkte
im gegensatz zu mir
aber wo müssen wir mal wie lange ich
weiß wo wie lange müssen
ach hier war ich doch schon war dabei
der begeisterung beim 1
ach ja kopiert oder center steht ja
jetzt solle mitte gehen center heißt mit
den leuten so einfach der bank you mario
bava sie würde ich mal mit ihr ausgehen
oh mann alter darauf habe ich noch
gehofft das geht nicht so weiter man
fühle mich echt vernachlässigt das sieht
man spielmodus wurde geändert ich bin
jetzt kreativ mode wo willst du ich hab
so ein schalter wurde ich creative mode
ehrlich ja warte komm ich zeig dir sich
zeigte klitschko creative mode rossis
alter in dem es heißt man junge baum
überhaupt creative mode com will dein
leben und verdammt
denn ernst das liegt da gerade drüber
ich habe ja soll ich dafür wenn du
keinen fall schaden bekommen ist aber
das bringt jetzt diese diskussion
natürlich nicht ich habe weil ich auf
die druckplatten gegangen bin
im gegensatz zu dir darum bin ich auch
genauso schnell vom kontron com wo lange
hier lang
da fehlt er war etwas energie her wie
kommt man da hoch da ist das so eine
platte hier vor ich glaube ihr tp ich
höre immer der tastatur da im
hintergrund immer so was für immer meine
tastatur mann ich will einmal so ein
kleines klicken
jetzt habe ich diese jump dingsda nicht
mehr
[Musik]
das kann ich niemals so jetzt aber ok
das kommt immer einen moment zu spät zu
spielen so das riecht irgendwie förmlich
nach einer kiste im wasser finde ich das
richtig
ja aber auch schon geschaut
ich habe auch mal auch alter immer ein
zu spät hier jetzt habe ich wieder nicht
die sprungliste geflogen
ja bin ich nun wieder sichtbar
die erste folge ich habe es geschafft
übrigens ich auch ich bin schon weiter
ich will es nicht ich glaube ich
schwimme jetzt mal im wasser verloren
macht das alles nichts und ich könnte
mir mal wieder irgendwo was habe ich
habe immer noch hier die ganzen youtuber
bürger aus gebratenen schweinefleisches
wollte ich gerade wieder durch schießt
ich glaube jetzt hervor weil sie ja dann
hinauf altar ich habe mir da wirklich
durch ist der dich so anspruchsvoll
möchte ich mal meinen doch für die
scholle
nein warum ich ihn sonst vor dir ja auch
nur ein kleines stück so hinterher
hinterher
ich rieche es schon irgendwo hier gleich
am ende am ende des langen ganges kommt
eine kiste die mist ich bin immer noch
sehr schnell das ist unglaublich ich
auch so aber ich bin auch gleich wieder
bei dir und nein manchmal regelrecht ein
du bist vorne machen wir uns stark und
nur damit du auf holen kannst ja mal
verstärkungen holen
das geht ja richtig gerade ab und es
geht richtig schnell gerade einfach nur
erträglich steil hier wird kein großer
hier weiter alter nicht gefallen ja man
jetzt bin ich aber nicht zu mir
[Musik]
darunter ist der branche walter ich bin
sogar schneller ist unglaublich ich habe
auch so er wir müssen übrigens mal
wieder jetzt in ihren stopp machen
er liegt jetzt schon den pool oder hast
du bist so richtig gemein ins wasser so
schön und gut so weiter dann geradezu
verhasst stopp gemacht dennoch nicht ach
so ja gut ich mache mich mal da
wiederhole einen stopp wir sehen uns
dann in der nächsten folge hat die auf
dem kanal wieder schließt und jetzt bald
und schön mit den schildern lippen